لدينا ما يكفي من الجنود ولا حاجه للتعبئه
هكذا ارعبت موسكو الغرب والبيت الابيض
يعلنها اوكرانيا ستتعرض للعقوبات لم ياتي
الهجوم المضاد بنتائج هنجاريا تعود الى
الاحضان الروسيه رغما عن الغربيين الاتحاد
الاوروبي يفتح ابوابه امام الاوكران ما
الغايه نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي يقدم
خبرين جيدين لنظام كيف النيتو يعلن حاله
الطوارئ بسبب اوكرانيا بيلاروسيا تحضر
جيشها بعدتها والعتاد ما الذي يجري زل
نسكي يتسببوا بعزل رئيسي مجلسي النواب في
امريكا وكندا والنواب الامريكان يعلقون
مجلسهم لمده اسبوع موسكو في اتم
الاستعداد الحرب هي كفتح باب غرفه مظلمه
لن تعرف ابدا ما الذي سيحصل عند فتح هذا
الباب هكذا قالها هتلر يوما ما نعم فوسط
الاسلحه والجيوش تصمت القوانين هنا سكت
الغرب قليلا ليكسروا قوانينهم بمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا حتى النهايه وها هو منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي يعلن ان
الولايات المتحده تعتقد انه لدى كيف ست
الى ثمانيه اسابيع متبقيه للهجوم المضاد
ماذا هل سمعتم ما قاله كيربي اذا هما
شهران فقط وبعدها ننتظر رده فعل واشنطن في
حال استمرار فشل الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
دعونا ننتظر حتى ذلك الحين اليكم
[موسيقى]
المصدر
من جهته اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شيجو انه لا خطط لتعبئه اضافيه للجنود
مبينا ان عدد المتطوعين الذين انضموا
للجيش هذا العام تجاوز
335000 واضاف انه في شهر سبتمبر واحده وقع
اكثر من 50 الف مواطن على العقود هذه
الاعداد تشكل رعبا لاوكرانيا وحلفائها
الغربيين فهل اقتربت النهايه لا لم تقترب
فالاتحاد الاوروبي يعيد بصيصا من الامل
لكييف حيث ذكرت صحيفه بوليتيكو نقلا عن
دبلوماسيين ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يستعد
لبدء مفاوضات رسميه مع اوكرانيا بشان
الانضمام ومن المتوقع صدور اعلان رسمي في
شهر ديسمبر المقبل لتدخل صحيفه فاينانشال
تايمز على الخط بذكرها نقلا عن ميزانيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان انضمام اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيعطي كيف حق الحصول على
حوالي
186 ملي ار يورو خلال سبع سنوات لكن في
المانيا يعارض الشعب سياسه الاتحاد
الاوروبي باكمله حيث يعارض سكان مدينه
جروس نهاين الالمانيه بناء مصنع للذخيره
لاوكرانيا في مدينتهم خشيه اغضاب الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وروسيا التي يفضلون
الحفاظ على السلام معها بحسب صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز اما حلف النيتو فاعلن
اعضائه حاله الطوارئ وذلك بتحذير لمسؤولين
في الحلف من قرب نف امدادات الجيوش
الغربيه من الذخيره التي يمكن تقديمها
لاوكرانيا وض المسؤولون الغربيون الدول
الداعمه لاوكرانيا على زياده الانتاج من
اجل استمرار كيف في القتال ضد روسيا لتنقل
وكاله سي ان ان عن رئيس اللجنه العسكريه
بالنيو رابير قوله ان الامدادات في مخازن
الذخيره في اوروبا باتت تقترب من نصف
محتوياتها او حتى اقل ليكشف نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي دمتري مدفيدف خبرين جيد
دين لنظام كييف على حد تعبيره الاول هو
اعتراف رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارل ميشيل
بان اوكرانيا ستنضم الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
بحلول عام 2030 وهو ما يعني ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعتقد ان دوله اتباع بنديره
ستستمر حتى ذلك الحين اما الثاني ولاول
مره في تاريخ الولايات المتحده يتم اقاله
رئيس مجلس النواب و على وجه التحديد بسبب
تعاطفه مع سلطات كيف والتنازلات فيم
الميزانيه لتمويل انصار بنديره بحسب قول
مدفيدف الذي اضاف فقط بقي التنويه على انه
لم يتبقى من المال سوى ما يكفي لشهرين لكن
ما الذي جرى حتى تتم اقاله رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي سنذكر لكم التفاصيل لاحقا
لنتجه الى هنغاريا التي تمضي في طريقها
نحو روسيا وترى مصالحها بعيدا عن اوروبا
والغرب فقد اكد وزير الخارجيه الهنغار
بيتر سيارتو ان هنغاريا مستعده بشكل جيد
لفصل الشتاء من خلال الحفاظ على التعاون
المنطقي مع روسيا وضمان امدادات موثوقه من
الطاقه وبعوده الى الميدان الاوكراني
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التصدي
لمحاوله اوكرانيه لتنفيذ هجوم بواسطه
صاروخ من طراز نبتون المضاد للسفن ضد
اهداف قباله سواحل شبه جزيره القرم اضافت
الوزاره الروسيه انها احبطت محاوله انزال
اوكرانيه في كيب تارخان كوت في شبه
الجزيره حيث حاولت القوات الاوكرانيه
تنفيذ هجوم عبر زوارق بحريه في وقت متاخر
من الليل شمال غربي البحر الاسود هذا
وقالت هيئه الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه
انها شهدت 43 اشتباكا مع القوات الروسيه
واكدت انها تواصل هجومها المضاد في اتجاه
ملتبل وباخ موت المقابل قصفت القوات
الروسيه تسع مناطقه في اوكرانيا وهاجمت
127 بلده لتعود الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن
الحصيله بالقضاء على اكثر من 500 جندي
اوكراني خلال يوم مع اسقاط مقاتله مك 29
و74 مسيره وتدمير مستودعات للاسلحه
والذخيره تابعه للجيش الاوكراني وها نحن
نتصفح المصدر امامكم في الموقع الرسمي
للحكومه الروسيه هنا ننتقل الى الجره
بيلاروسيا حيث اعلنت وزاره دفاعها اطلاق
اختبار دوري لجوزيه الجيش البيلاروسي
بتوجيه من رئيس البلاد الكساندر لوكاشينكو
ومن المقرر تنفيذ تحركات ميدانيه للاليات
العسكريه والافراد على طول الطرق العامه
في منطقتي مسك و فيتبسك واستخدام الطيران
الحربي لدعم تحركات القوات البريه هل هناك
رساله الى بولندا بهذه التحركات عدوى نكسه
زيلنسكي
صخب عالمي واسع يرتفع ل تشهده مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي عقب عزل رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن مكارثي حيث ربط
المستخدمون بين عزله واستقاله رئيس
البرلمان الكندي عقب زياره زيلينسكي لكن
هل تفكرون كما افكر زيلينسكي زار الولايات
المتحده قبل وصوله الى كندا وبعد تلك
الزيارتين تمت ازاحه رئيسي مجلسي النواب
في البلدين الكبيرين وهذا ما جناه الغرب
على انفسهم بوضع كامل ثقتهم في الرئيس
الاوكراني وما هذه الا البدايه ك ما تقول
التقارير الرئيس الامريكي قد يخسر منصبه
في الانتخابات القادمه لسبب ذاته هنا نعود
الى الولايات المتحده حيث كان اعضاء مجلس
النواب قد صوتوا على عزل رئيس المجلس
الجمهوري كيفن مكارثي في سابقه هي الاولى
في تاريخ الولايات المتحده ليعلق المجلس
جلساته لمده اسبوع بانتظار الرئيس الجديد
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قد دعا الى
المسارعه الى انتخاب رئيس جديد لمجلس الن
فيما تم اعلان باتريك ماكري رئيسا مؤقتا
لمجلس النواب الامريكي وفي اول قرار له
قام ماكهنري بطرد البسوس نسي بيلوسي رئيسه
مجلس النواب السابقه من الكابيتول وامرها
باخلاء
[موسيقى]
مكتبها
ه